I don't want to say a peach because I'm
very young yeah but I think I just did
[Music]
what's up guys it's Clark and Alisa and
my girl de Lisa here she is from Houston
and I'm from Arlington Texas I've been
here Neil for about five years and she
just moved to New York so I want to show
her that New York knows how to do
barbecue so I texted some of my Texas
friends and I got some of the best
recommendations and so now I want to see
like what she thinks is the best Texas
barbecue in NYC I will be honest I'm a
little skeptical I'm interested to see
maybe I'll eat my words right now I'm
eat these ribs yeah and see if New York
can put it down let's see what you don't
find it tastes our own let's do it all
right this is feta cell which is German
for fat pig so you already know that
they're doing it okay very no-frills
very true like how the Central Texas
barbecue is so I know you said you
wanted ribs let's try these rid of that
way first was that is Johnny as Hale you
know the food's go and I can't say
anything that strong salty taste of the
pork rib do something like lightly sweet
on there but no so a roll yeah it's real
like Hawaiian rolls
oh I love this place already this is a
good piece of prison they're cheap dick
sonny big Rotech thick with too few the
good thing about New York
is it attracts people from everywhere so
you get southerners coming the grittier
taste of the south this is their pork
belly they said we had to try it oh [ __ ]
barking through it
[ __ ] the little data this is Lone
Star proof okay thank you guys what did
you think of finished out it really
exceeded my expectations and we ran into
a fellow BBQ lover due to his next
recommendation barbecue stop number two
with no country barbecue and Manhattan
it's country music playing yeah this is
what Texas feels like can we stop
talking up long let's start with ribs
this was a pretty rig like this look
pretty when I picked it up he condition
smokiness of the wood she knows is like
done done alright I don't know man
he's a bed-stuy boy Brooklyn born and
raised given a little like sweet taste
without the sauce this is good big
squared this is low star fruit yeah I'm
with it right now
good I need a napkin it's not called
napkin licking good breath this sausage
is flavorful okay well it feels like
home
thank you for coming with us gonna stir
knee good to know that this is also
Brooklyn approve find you a barbecue
that they can do both and last up we've
got blue smoke
these are my roots yeah this is my home
I said the best for last like I hope
this oppressed is you know me you wanted
ribs so you got rid this is what Texas
does best
is the beef ribs it's truly over car
that's already over looking good
oh wow this might be a second
bad to the phone as long starfruit so we
have reached the end of our Texans
journey for the best barbecue in New
York City what are your thoughts we
started out with sunny South for those
bougie barbecue connoisseurs
that's her one-stop shop you got great
ass food simplistic Texas feel took it
on down a hill country I felt like I was
back home
chillin with my friends that will do it
on a dirt road it's like the full Texas
experience in this place like just a
craftsmanship that goes into this
befriended me see this spring I feel
like this is a place like take a ticket
date Oh like how do y'all turn the sound
like yeah like if you're trying I'm
impressed
you did a great job Clark thank you
now whenever I need a taste of home we
know it's not the way to go
Cheers so let's just let's just even
think about Texas we have a montage
how you doing buddy wedding
in the camp focus on work
but I've never been more content my life
once our brews
[Music]